Hartman's pass connects with Eric senet
and Johanson Wheels to Center Johansson
fires and a save by Murray rebound just
out of the reach of ericon Rossi sends
it around behind for bagoan bagoan playing
with Damon hunt here in this game gagoski
a stratch for Minnesota zukar in fires
from the wall saved by Murray Lindell
on the rebound rolls right out front
a chance for Baldi and it's deflected
away wild still with it Merill moves in a shot
saved by Murray Long rebound meris the drive
glove save Murray and the wild are pressuring
early Puck comes back down into the wild Zone
but Minnesota's efficiently out Middleton
has it pushes ahead to Maroon Tred to go
back to Middleton Pino got it back to Maroon
a shot right on and a save by Murray Hartman
Johansson line against the high-scoring trio of
Robertson Hinson pelski centering pass Hartman
a shot and a save he goes cross ice for baly
up high Faber moves to the middle goes back to
baly Faber again zuk Carell fires and it's
tipped out front off the glass Steel on it
there for Dallas back to goodro in the slot
Hartman a shot wanted it tip by Maroon just
missed Johansson to hunt hunt with a long
shot gloved by Murray and he hangs on cut
off by haw andpa he goes up high to Hartman
hunt Johansson back to hunt Hartman a drive
kick save Murray here at home this weekend
starting with that Friday game against
Philadelphia rro plays to Maroon rare spot here
where Minnesota has the upper hand in terms of
Power Play Chances early in a game Dallas the
second least penalized team in the league and
hint score short-handed on the turnover
from the side of the net he beats flurry
up over the stick side and the stars who have
been dangerous short-handed all year of their
eighth shorty of the season and a one Zer lead
veteran comes up the ice pressure he does a good
job settling this thing down a little backhand
sauce to his streaking rupe h no chance for Mark
Andre flurry but stick placement from San Rossi
kind of caught in between I mean you're reading
that play you don't know what to do Mark Andre a
full College season right now playing 30 minutes
a night is it taxing will we start to see some
tired mistakes here's Faber in the high slot
looking goes to Baldi side of the net Ericson
a tried to tuck one in it's deflected to the
corner Rossi moves down to the corner up high
Baldi Baldi flings one through and a save by
Murray maroon plays it around for gdo out to Faber
moving in a shot saved by Murray ban centers Tipp
by Maroon actually hit to drow now B Goan another
shot pad Sav by Murray hunk holds the line for
Minnesota suder had it knocked away maroon out
front for Felino he was tied up by Suter could
get the redirect shot to flex to the corner faxa
to danov who comes up high with it his shot def
Flex through hit the post Puck is loose and a
great stick knocks It Away by rasa Jamie Ben
bagoan breaks that one up and then danov off the
post a bouncing Puck then as Ras in good defensive
position he comes back to help out again Johansson
walk lost the handle on it plays it to Hartman
back of the net Hartman for Ericson EA shot a Sav
by Murray another good look for Minnesota Power
Play Chance For The Stars Power Play Goals in
four of their last five Roberts in a shot saved by
flurry puts on the brakes
tried to center it deflex
wide of flurry out to the line Suter
a long wrist shot and a save by flurry
Faber up the boards paxa kicks it down to
the corner to keep it alive paxa circles
from behind the net a shot by haena it pops up
in the air it's still available at the side of
the net and FY somehow comes up with this Puck
trying to locate this it's bouncing on front
after hitting the stick it's an unbelievable
glove save watch this quick twitch with the
left hand another great glove save add that to
the Highlight Reel Long Shot by Harley and that
a point blanker from pavelski and a pad saved by
flurry well Dallas isn't getting much by way of
quantity with a nice one then off the draw here
and the broken plays I mean the pucks up in the
air fa up high zuk Carell to Baldi back to Faber
a drive tip save Murray rebound was loose for a
moment and Murray has it covered the scene pass
from Mad zuk Carell all of a sudden you can see
the kill kind of sink and get back towards
their box in their paint and sitting deep
is faxa boy that one just catches small piece
of the Blocker of Murray inside almost on the
thumb portion of it but it sits there pavelski
at Center to Robertson moving in he has hints
with him Robertson a shot in a glove saved by
flurry Mount some pressure it's still one Zer
Stars rossie tried to go cross ice to Baldi
San back on the attack for Dallas a shot saved
by flurry no it trickled through him flurry
thinks it was over the line it was waved off
flurry slams the stick on the ice they'll take
a closer look at this this was very close to
trickling over the line as it sneaked through
flurry Stars think they've scored and the way
flurry acted I think he knows it was in well
you read the te leaves yeah Mark Andre flurry
had the best look at that one he turns around
second just coming down and quick rer catches
Mark Andre flurry right in the armpit the play
is under review to determine if the puck cross
the goal line yeah mma's just given sing a
little bit too much room and respect on that
shot he eles to go for the slash to stick
on Puck and that allows San to get the shot
off this might be their last
chance a two-on-one shorthanded for Dallas
sing to hints and he missed it put it right
back into Mark Andre flurry and flurry Joe
Hanson weaves his way in good row trying to
get it back to hunt but that pass is intercepted
and steel short-handed for Dallas back to faxa he
scores a second short-handed goal tonight
four this season by the Stars Against the
Wild and it's 30 Dallas ances on that power
play Dallas two wild zero and Freddy goodro
tries to take the outside I on steel that's
a mistake he wants to get underneath that
allows the passing Lane over to faxa Damon
hunt inexperienced sagging a little bit too
much he's got to read that back pressure
just allow Steel goodro in short-handed
for Minnesota tried to Center to Middleton
deflected off a stick and hints plays to
Harley hints for Ben back across to
Robertson he scores and it's a power
play goal for Dallas it's now a 40 lead
coming unhinged all of a sudden to Zone
entries clean Robertson picks this
one up uncovered he's able to just
pick the head up and snap one through
Mark Andre flurry short side under the
glove special teams for Dallas and
it'll be five losses in the last six
games for Minnesota with the same two
teams meeting in Dallas on Wednesday
night